The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
So I think it's about
time to get started.
So good afternoon.
So let me see.
So what do you think about
[? Genco? ?] [? Or Genco, ?] I
guess.
[? Genco ?] [? Genco? ?]
You never know.
It was a good talk.
I enjoyed it.
Did you enjoy it?
Yeah, it was interesting.
So let's talk about the-- just
to kind of refresh your memory.
And then we move
into the two more
things I want to cover today.
We want to cover the
willful case study-- kind of
to close this notion
of reverse logistics
and closed-loop supply
chains a little bit.
But before we start, we read
quickly a study of ReCellular
that was really try to connect
with some of the things that we
heard from [? Genco-- ?]
[? Genco? ?] Genco.
And I wanted to know-- I read
the responses, the homework,
and you were split.
So some of you did think
that ReCellular had a future,
and others thought that
they were beginning
to disappear as a company.
So who wants to be the
voice of ReCellular-- well,
before we start, well, since
this is your first time I see
you here-- you were traveling.
So do you remember what
is the basic business
model of ReCellular?
AUDIENCE:Yeah, I do. [INAUDIBLE]
I was one of the guys for it,
actually.
PROFESSOR: Well, it's all great.
So why don't you give us a quick
recap of what ReCellular does?
Just in 10 minutes or less.
AUDIENCE: They are-- [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A couple minutes, OK?
AUDIENCE: --cellphones and
repurposing them and selling
them to other markets--
markets that, you know,
may think those cell--
give us certain value
for those secondhand cellphones.
And they get them
from various sources,
including the donation bin
type sources as well as
some higher quality sources.
PROFESSOR: Great.
So who else was in favor, or
thought that the ReCellular
model had some future?
Four?
So who wants to--
[? Marianna? ?]
Do you want to try to do it?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Give your pitch.
AUDIENCE: Well, my
[INAUDIBLE] I think
they have a future
because people
who always consume cellphones.
They might evolve
into something else,
like we have seen it [INAUDIBLE]
composites or something.
But that same instrument
to talk and surf the web,
and what we're doing now
with phones will evolve,
and they can tap
into that industry.
It might not be cellphones,
but it will something else.
And they can tap into
that and reach-- as long
as they keep up with it.
Which I think by them
going to the e-commerce
gives them a good
sign that management
is doing a good job of
keeping up with technology
and making it,
keeping it global.
So I think that's why
I see a good future.
PROFESSOR: What do you
think is the biggest
bottleneck of ReCellular?
AUDIENCE: The fast evolution
of equipment, of the technology
is a thing.
The other one is as they
say the standards are not
the same in all countries.
However, the fact that
they have different markets
in each country also
works in their advantage.
For example, in
Latin America, you
get equipment that
is refurbished,
and it, you don't, doesn't care.
You have the technology in hand.
And I'm sure it's the same
in developing countries.
And I see that as working
to their advantage,
as well, for that.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
So someone that doesn't think
ReCellular has a chance?
AUDIENCE:I guess they've got
their current business model
getting donated cellphones
just wasn't viable because, you
know, there was a
time when, you know,
people usually got their
cellphone for free.
And then after two years ago,
they got another one for free,
and they said, OK.
I don't need this anymore.
And they throw it
in the donation bin.
But now people pay lot of
money for their cellphone.
And they want some
of that value back,
or they still see
the value at the end,
so they have to shift their
model where maybe they're
actually paying you
at this kind of rate
for someone's old cellphone.
Which you see now,
like [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We cannot hear anything
at all from here.
You can hear me,
but nobody else.
So Michael can you
help us with the mics?
I'll try to repeat in a sec,
but keep going then please.
AUDIENCE: At
[? least ?] I think they
have to shift towards
basically purchasing
these phones from people,
not relying so much
off of third-party collectors
if they want remain viable.
PROFESSOR: So your main concern
is that the shifting business
model of cellphones
or electronics
is you're paying for
them, that you don't
want to donate it anymore.
And that's kind of the
main way how ReCellular
is trying to make money
is by getting them donated
and trying to make money
out of that donation.
So basically you're
arguing that there may not
be enough residual
value to buy a phone,
because they could pay a
little bit for it, right?
And then they will--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Can't rely
so much as getting it
to the third-party collectors.
PROFESSOR: But you
think they pay for it ,
will that make them viable?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Somebody that's doesn't agree.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
the point of-- I don't think
it'll, it'll--
PROFESSOR: I'm checking
to see if they could hear.
AUDIENCE: Can they?
PROFESSOR: Can you
hear right now,
or the same as [? before? ?]
Can you hear better?
AUDIENCE: Yes,
[? it is better. ?]
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I think the
business model was more viable
the beginning where the
cellular industry was starting,
and part of lifetime like
was [? say ?] much longer.
But now you have new
models coming all the time,
and that significantly
decreases the price they
you can get for a
secondhand phone.
So for example, previously
maybe you had, I don't know,
50 models of cellphones
come out in a year,
and now you might have 200.
I don't know.
I'm making the numbers up, but
you do have much more offers
right now.
So the price you can get is
pretty, I think it'll decline.
And as a result, you'll
have less revenue,
so I don't think
that it's so viable.
PROFESSOR: OK
AUDIENCE: I think to add onto
the point, right now, I mean,
we're talking about
enough, almost like one
to one ratio of cellphones
and people on Earth.
So we're talking about
large manufacturing volumes,
which means that the cost,
the price has also decreased.
So that would decrease
the attractiveness
of secondhand phones.
And also, I mean,
that differential
that ReCellular is trying
to play on-- how much they
buy the phones as
compared to how much they
can sell the phones.
PROFESSOR: So it is
shrinking margins
that you think are
going to be a problem.
So you want to go back and
say why ReCellular can still
make money.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And I mean like a good
point that was raised,
I think one first
thing about prices--
I don't think that
the price going down
is bad from the
customer's perspective.
And what I used is
technology lifecycle model.
So there is a lot of innovation.
And there are early adopters
in the early majority,
but there are also
laggards and people
who are not adopting
the [INAUDIBLE]
and who are just really happy
to have really low-priced phone
because they value
more the price rather
than the technology.
And so there's at least one
third or more of the market
that is actually asking
for the secondary phones
because they don't value
as much the technology.
And they have just more
choice because a lot
of different phones
actually that
are being put on the market.
[INAUDIBLE] so those people
have actually larger choice
for like a lower price.
And from a customer perspective
and from a demand standpoint,
I think this is a good thing.
And so the business
model might have
to change a little bit because
they will have more margins
or so, but they have demand.
So they do the right
adjustments [INAUDIBLE]
and they have
quality [INAUDIBLE]
that quality of phone offered.
I think that is really
a way to make their way
through the secondary market.
PROFESSOR: So the
argument here is
that even though the margin
could shrink over time,
there's always an adoption
of any technology.
There's always laggards.
So there's always a
market, basically.
Yeah?
The question is,
well, you probably
have to be more efficient
or-- so part of the argument
is they are the first.
If you are among the first,
you could probably get scale,
and you can be more competitive.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Part of my
reason for thinking
they're not going
to last is that they
do one and only one thing.
And we find all the time that
companies who do one thing
don't survive when
the next disruptive
technology comes along.
I guess what I'm
saying I disagree
with the fundamental assumption
that people will always
have cellphones.
That's what we
said about horses.
That's what we said
about newspapers.
Things go away
AUDIENCE: I said that
they would evolve.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So maybe There is
the electronics
so they need to add
something else, yeah?
AUDIENCE: And also [INAUDIBLE]
emerging countries.
The cellphones [INAUDIBLE]
large market to penetrate.
And we can see that
with mobile payment.
People are just buying
phones when there's really
accessing ways to pay for
those phones because it's also
[INAUDIBLE].
So even if we at some
point in the future
don't have phones anymore,
they can still in the meantime
sell to other people.
And what I think is
that they can adapt.
And if they, if we don't
have phones at some point,
and we have something
else, then we
can sell [INAUDIBLE] something
else to people afterwards.
So this [? big timeline ?]
still goes on.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's say I just check with
our friends from Zaragoza.
Do you hear any of
that discussion?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We heard part of it, so--
PROFESSOR: OK?
AUDIENCE: It's OK.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
Just want to double check.
All right so here's
the challenge, right?
So we, I am hopeful that
ReCellular can survive,
or one way or the other.
But the question is what
happens when ReCellular does not
survive?
There's not a
business to be made.
So, what will happen
with those phones?
AUDIENCE:
[? Genco will ?] get them.
PROFESSOR:
Yeah.
So the we heard
that the difference
is ReCellular is a specialized,
very niche, reverse logistics
provider.
Genco is completely diversified.
So they take anything
that their are
customers want-- in this case,
the customers is the retailers.
The customers is the
[? rest. ?] So I think that is,
what many of you pointed out,
one of the big differences is
Genco's with its [? moral ?] is
more towards partnership with
the retailers.
Really, that's their customer.
ReCellular, on the
other hand, wants
to go to the end customer.
They want to get us more
engaged one way or the other.
Of course, most of their
purchases come from dealers.
So they have another option.
And they try to go to
end consumers to try
to penetrate the market more.
But it's a challenging
environment.
Which gets us to Whirlpool.
Whirlpool, Whirlpool, Whirlpool.
So what do we do with Whirlpool?
So the way I would like to
start-- any other comments?
I cannot, not sure if they're
going to survive or not.
But--
AUDIENCE: Every time a fly to
Brazil, I can pay for my ticket
by reselling the cellphone
that's in my pocket.
There's definitely a
future for ReCellular.
PROFESSOR: There's-- hopefully
there's enough market.
And I believe there's enough,
but there's lots of pressures.
To be honest, I
[? see ?] becomes
the margins lower and lower.
Who knows.
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
I didn't see exactly
when that was published.
Oh.
This case was five
years ago, or so?
So it's a little bit older.
So ReCellular is still around.
I don't know how good are they
right now-- thriving or not.
OK, good.
So let's go to Whirlpool.
Unless there's any other
closing comments or questions
about ReCellular or Genco?
Zaragoza, any
comments or questions?
Final thoughts?
No?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Remember wave--
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PROFESSOR: --the hands.
Otherwise, I cannot see you.
All right.
So let's go to Whirlpool.
And to do Whirlpool,
we're going to spend
a little bit more time on it.
And what we will start with
is who wants to tell me
what should Whirlpool do?
So what, which are the
choices of Whirlpool?
Let's start with you.
AUDIENCE: So the choices are
to go with the IFO model--
PROFESSOR: Can you
explain what IFO is?
Quickly?
AUDIENCE: So the IFO is an
industry-funded organization
in which-- it's from
what I understand,
it's kind of like a third
party that kind of collects--
you know, it's owned by
all these industry players,
and they collect the
appliances, and then [INAUDIBLE]
with the public.
PROFESSOR: So if we're
pulling at words-- Genco,
but funded by a bunch of
[? same ?] the suplex.
And they all pay Genco,
and Genco does it.
Pretty much.
AUDIENCE: Another
way, a second method
is for Whirlpool to
be an IFO on it's own,
or to run a closed-loop system.
And collect their own
appliances at the end of life.
PROFESSOR: Closed-loop
system-- so in this context,
we probably have not defined
closed-loop properly.
It's just the same company
that sells a product,
wants to get it back.
And try to keep it within
your own system, as opposed
to getting somebody else to deal
with it and take care of it.
And you want to somehow extract
value out of the process
and bring those materials
back into your same supply
chain as best as possible.
And that's why the option
and this closed-loop
is closed loop-- doing it alone.
[? A little bit ?] alone,
at least it cannot, right?
Do it by why will they even--
AUDIENCE: There's
a third option--
PROFESSOR: Which is?
AUDIENCE: -which
is to do nothing.
PROFESSOR: Ah.
Third option.
Of course.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: More
than do nothing Do
nothing is no longer an option.
Do nothing was an option
maybe in 2005 for these guys.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I know.
I know what you meant.
Yeah.
So third option is to
oppose the regulation.
Oppose the regulation.
So let me start doing with
a little show of hands.
How many people think
that they should
go with the
industry-funded option?
Zaragoza one, two,
any one there?
That's two people.
AUDIENCE: Two and a half.
PROFESSOR: Two and a half?
No halves here.
AUDIENCE: I'm doing, I'm
going with three and then one.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK.
So if it doesn't work?
Two.
How many would like
to oppose regulation?
One, two, three?
Look like there's three.
So I take the rest of you would
like to do it on your own,
right?
So let's start with
the-- so you already
spoke-- who else wants
to oppose regulation?
Why would you oppose regulation?
AUDIENCE: Well,
can I also qualify
to say if I had to be one
or two, I would pick two.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But the idea
was that it's not really
be helpful because a
lot of this process
is self-sufficient
to begin with.
I think they said like 95%
of all of these products
go to the recycling process
and hardly any of it
go to the landfill just because
there's a lot of commodities
that are in these
products like aluminum,
or aluminium-- whatever--
copper, stuff like that.
So all this stuff
gets reclaimed.
So you don't need to
do something that's
going to add a lot of overhead
to people's businesses
to have them do something that's
pretty much already happening
on its own.
PROFESSOR: So it
happens on its own.
What are the rates?
Someone remembers of recycling?
AUDIENCE: It's like 95% to 99%.
That's pretty good, right?
AUDIENCE: Those were
Whirlpool's numbers.
PROFESSOR: They're pretty
good, pretty consistent.
Let's trust them.
These are factual numbers.
So 95% of it is kind of being
naturally repurposed, recycled
in some way or another
through our normal network.
We're going back
to, we're discussing
all the different products--
cars and t-shirts.
Cars have a lot of value.
Appliances have a lot of value.
They're designed for a
very, very long time.
So someone wants to
kind of move that chain
of how much value having the
latest model of refrigerator
or not.
And eventually when it goes
to the bottom of that chain,
that person also wants
to maybe make the effort
to try to get some value.
And a dealer gets it and
scraps it and divides it
into all the metals and
eventually gets done.
AUDIENCE: I would argue it's
more of an effort for someone
not to recycle their
old washing machine,
to like pick it up and
take it to the landfill.
It's not like you're
throwing away batteries.
I mean, most people
get rid of their stuff
by putting it outside
in front of their house,
and then someone picks it up.
So if the process already works?
Like those 5% who aren't
recycling it, or whatever,
they're probably not going to
just because Whirlpool came up
with a closed-loop system.
So it's really not
going to add any--
PROFESSOR: So those 5%
have their own landfills.
They will still trash it, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK. they'll
leave it there hanging.
Those are the ones that are
not accounted for, right?
Those are the ones that
are still your houses,
landfill somewhere.
OK, good.
So what is-- yeah?
You want to add
something else on the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just want to
[? comment made ?] I think that
the problem with that even
though it seems to be working,
[? it's like ?] perpetuates a
mentality that I can just put
something out on my,
you know, on my driveway
or on the sidewalk and someone
else will take care of it.
And I think that's a big issue
in the US at least [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this
is the working part
is that it naturally
the market is.
But there's something about the
overall social norms changes
that you would like to maybe to?
So this is part
of a trend, right?
So this is Canada, right?
We're not talking
about the US here.
It's Canada so people
are very conscious.
They're already doing
lots of recycling.
There's lots of other
programs going on.
Eh?
So this is natural progression.
But a couple of
people that maybe--
who thought that the one
regulation is still not enough.
So one reason is social.
Which is the other reason?
AUDIENCE: Well, I [INAUDIBLE]
prices of all the cohesion
are pretty high, but what
happens if at some point
the prices are not high enough
to give incentive to recycle?
There's a second point.
And also [INAUDIBLE] new
regulations [INAUDIBLE] There's
an example about mercury.
They may need to
regulate mercury,
how we get that mercury.
How will we show that all
the scavengers that deal
with maybe some of the
material correctly so
the person [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Refridgerant,
for example.
PROFESSOR: Refrigerant.
So there's a couple
of things that we
know that they are recycled.
We know that those materials
are being somehow repurposed--
a big chunk of them.
So the problem is that if
the prices change, boom.
This market will collapse.
Maybe there's
innovation in materials.
And they come up
with a new material
that is an alloy-- plastic.
Who knows-- that is
still as good performing
as the need for the
structure of the refrigerator
that is not as recyclable
or is very expensive.
And then you have
much [? our ?] waste.
So there's a little bit
of an uncertainty factor.
Then clearly what
they're trying to get out
of it what is the
most value and what
they know how to deal with.
And mercury and refrigerants
are a little more tricky.
And it's unclear to know if
if they're doing properly.
So there's a little bit
of a tricky part there.
But there may be other
options of regulation
instead of these ones.
So this is the regulation
that what they are opposing
is the extended producers'
responsibility, the EPR
responsibility.
That is Whirlpool
is to be responsible
over the whole thing.
But there are other
things that could do.
Adjust to tackle mercury and
refrigerant, for example.
What could they do if they
only want to fix that problem?
Why would the government,
what could the government do?
Without doing this whole,
very complicated process?
AUDIENCE: It's what
they're doing to laptops.
They just ban the product, or
ban the hazardous material.
PROFESSOR: So some
pieces you can
ask manufacturers to phase
this out of their products
altogether, right?
So you work with
the manufacturers,
and you so some sort of
agreement, technology path.
And then eventually you
can get rid of that.
That's one option.
Any other options?
Zaragoza, any other options?
They're silent today.
AUDIENCE: We have
the mic off just
to make sure we don't have echo.
PROFESSOR: So any other options?
AUDIENCE: Guys?
PROFESSOR: No options.
The other one is to try
these dealers, maybe,
right-- these current
recyclers and train them to do
better mercury management?
You can do a whole program,
right, where you can
just instead of
involving everyone
you just go to the market
directly and do it.
Those are a few things you
could do instead of regulation.
But let's move to the
other two options.
IFO versus closed loop--
who chose the IFO more?
So, well, no one in Zaragoza,
so maybe I'll give you a chance.
So why will the IFO model be
a good chance for Whirlpool?
AUDIENCE: Well, I voted
for that because that
leaves time and flexibility
for the regulation to change.
I said if you go with an
IFO, gives you more time
to see how things
[? structure ?] really works,
how they can look internally
to see how the closed loop can
be designed [INAUDIBLE].
I thought more as a
temporary solution,
and then because it's way
more expensive, right?
It would take three,
four times according
to my garbage to go through.
So I said do it for
a period of time,
and then once you
change the closed group,
you can pay back an actually
meet how the regulation would
go [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this is
like a good, safe place
to start the process.
AUDIENCE: To start.
And then move ahead
either regulation change
or the closed loop.
Turns out to be more
effective than expected.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So what do you say about that?
AUDIENCE: I haven't been because
I'm still not on Stellar.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're
still not on Stellar.
AUDIENCE: My first class.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
All right.
So they--
AUDIENCE: I said that you
should go with a closed loop
because, I think,
assuming that you're
going to have to
get there eventually
even though it's
more start-up costs.
Putting the time in and
getting the jump on it
could make them
a leader in this.
If they know they're
going to go there,
and they already have started
to make their machines more
[? grave, ?] then they
can stand to benefit
from optimizing their processes
and manufacturing their system
vice continuing
to pay for people
who aren't as advanced as
they are with their recycling
technology.
AUDIENCE: Adding to that, you
also address customer loyalty.
Not only are you there when
they start using [INAUDIBLE]
actually have a lot of
impact in a future sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] common
culture is very in-house
[INAUDIBLE] doing their own
thing so I [? thought ?]
the closed loop, maybe
like [INAUDIBLE] [? as ?]
the industry will grow they
will say to the customer how
important it is to
have [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Do you want to defend
your IFO choice?
So basically why I
chose IFO was as to me
so I worked under the assumption
that legislation would pass
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
the legislation passed soon,
and that there are
fines for not complying,
you going to closed loop you
have to develop a logistics
system that's really, that
gets to every part of Canada,
basically.
Which is a huge country.
And you need to make investments
in, for example, vehicles
to pick up the
refrigerators and the ovens,
the washing machines,
and all this.
So I believe that this
was too much of a cost
to effectively reach all of
the customers that it has.
And that under the IFO model
since there was something
consolidated, you
were taking advantage
of the economies of
scale of, well, you
would reach all the
customers in all of Canada,
but for not just
30% of the market,
but for the entire
100% of the market.
And you get the economies
of scale of that.
PROFESSOR: So if I make
[INAUDIBLE] this argument is,
well, I can make investment
money many, many places, right?
I could invest in
better products.
I could invest maybe
in other places.
So why should I put my money
in developing this new network
if I could just pull my
resources with others.
And then try to make,
pay potentially less.
We'll talk about the
cost later, yeah?
And decide what happens.
Do you want to add
something to the argument?
AUDIENCE: Speaking of
the economies of scale,
95% to around 95%
of the machines
are currently not making
their way to the landfill.
I'm not sure that there's
an economy of scale
to justify the up-front costs
for a closed-loop system.
PROFESSOR: So, yeah, so there's
not even enough volume even,
right?
Because people are
naturally recycling.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] about
these costs and [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So here you
have, you control the costs.
Here you may get scale.
Maybe.
Maybe, right?
The scale is much
more certain here.
Here you control the cost more.
OK, great.
So those are the options.
And it's hard to make a call
here without some number.
So who is brave enough to walk
us through their calculations
on how much this thing
cost for Whirlpool?
Let's try to make a
few estimates to see
and try to make a decision
is this really more expensive
or not.
From an industry IFO
versus the closed loop.
So what I'll do is maybe someone
is willing to risk and tell me
how much is the cost per
ton of doing an IFO model.
Do you remember?
I have your [? papers ?] here
so [? someone ?] I can open it,
or your document, I can
be happy to open it.
So we see how do you
get to that number.
Because those are
numbers you have
to do eventually if you
want to analyze the systems.
So what is the cost per ton
more or less, or per pound?
I'm sure all of you computed
to get these numbers.
Let me get mine here.
See more or less what they were.
Someone remembers?
How much money will
this cost to Whirlpool?
Total money.
You remember?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: How many?
AUDIENCE: $35 million.
PROFESSOR: $35 million.
AUDIENCE: [? Since ?] 2008.
AUDIENCE: IFO?
AUDIENCE: IFO, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: That's
based on the fact
that there's 100 kilotons
of stuff being thrown away.
And 30% of it is Whirlpool.
And then I found some data
somewhere in a case study that
had dollar per
ton, and I applied
the collection, transport
and processing--
numbers that were there.
PROFESSOR: So there
was [? an existing ?]
to how all of this cost
per ton of collection,
dollars, et cetera, et cetera.
And you can apply that.
You add it up that
gives you roughly
like $1,000 or something
of the collection costs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I assumed the most
expensive route
for the trucks, and the
full trucks, as well.
PROFESSOR: And that gave you
like $35 million to do IFO.
AUDIENCE: For 2008, yeah.
PROFESSOR: For 2008 figures.
AUDIENCE: I did something
similar with average numbers
and ended up same
ballpark-- $24 million.
PROFESSOR: $24 million?
$10 million more.
I will argue.
But still-- it's a big number.
It's a big ballpark.
Someone got a different number?
So that looks like a big
number, but how big is it
compared to what it will cost--
AUDIENCE: It's tiny.
They spend $202 million to ship
the stuff out to customers.
How much they spend?
200 and-- how'd
you get the number?
220 million.
Other assumptions.
I assumed $40 per
appliance delivery--
PROFESSOR: How much
was the, $40 per--
AUDIENCE: $40 per
appliance delivery, yeah?
And 5 million appliances, large
appliances shipped in 2008.
Mind you that's I didn't
take the 30% of that number,
so it would be 30% of $202
million, so about $70 million--
PROFESSOR: Around $70 million
AUDIENCE: --for
Whirlpool washers.
PROFESSOR: So that would be
about this number [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I'm sure
it was about right.
AUDIENCE: That number
is going on the customer
in terms of the delivery fee.
PROFESSOR: And it says that
it counts for the costs
so the customer does pay for it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: --right
now for the retailer.
But this is the collection fees.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but I'm just
saying like right now like they
haven't, their cost for delivery
isn't really a cost to them
because they're probably making
money off of the delivery,
you know.
They're probably charging
more than it actually costs.
So, I mean, just a footnote.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's-- so to build to make
this choices we have to make
these calculations right.
So the number I got--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The numbers I have are more
towards the $35 million,
but for 2020 numbers,
no 2008 numbers.
Why 2020?
Remember that in
some way you only
see things that are discarded.
The things that are kind of
naturally progress from one
place to the other,
you don't see those.
The Whirlpool case had a table
somewhere-- exhibit seven--
and this gives you a sense of
the units discarded in 2020.
So those are the total discarded
units of all different kinds
of appliances.
So you can get
their refrigerators,
freezers, dishwashers,
cooking ranges, [INAUDIBLE]
[? and some ?] washers
and so forth, yeah?
Then there's a table,
I think on top,
that has more or less the amount
of steel, aluminum, copper, et
cetera, and the weight
of each appliance.
So you can get the total
number of appliances
times the weight of
those appliances,
and they give you how many
tons you have to let's
say, get back.
Once you compute those
tons you need to get back,
those are now all yours, right?
You'll be responsible
for your market share.
You said 30%, but
actually Whirlpool
does Whirlpool and Kenmore.
So it's close to 48% more
or less of the market.
48% of the market share, and
then you get those numbers.
And that's the total tonnage.
So what you can sell,
you make money out of it.
Because you can sell it, right?
You get it and you
make money out of it.
And then you pay, and
that's the tricky part.
There's a collection
cost on exhibit four.
It's a collection per ton.
That's come from the previous
program, [? the We ?] program.
And it says, roughly-- you
know, in the [? We ?] program
is an IFO program.
It gives you $165
to collect per ton.
And you can then add
all those numbers,
and it gives you $37 million.
I'll put a table,
but those are more,
those are rough
numbers that you get.
And I give you 7 million
for the cost for doing this.
Which translates into a
$47 per unit more or less.
So the cost of IFO is
equal to $47 per unit sold.
$47 per unit.
How does that compare to
their distribution costs?
That's how we know
it's expensive or not.
How do you compute the
distribution cost of Whirlpool?
Someone did that?
So we know more [? than ?]
to compare how they do it.
That's the reverse
part-- $47 per unit.
AUDIENCE: Well, if I
know it's different,
so I did do it with 30%
of market share, not 48%.
But they said that it's
approximate for the industry
standard 10% of their sales.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so I
would say that they
were selling [INAUDIBLE]
per 100,000 units
but that's 30% of the market.
And you change it to 48%.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but
that's the right number.
So the approximate
costs are 10%.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so it changes--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So now there's another
number somewhere in the case
that is $1,000 per unit.
That's the average retail price.
Now you can also assume
a margin, you know,
of a retailer.
30% margin, 25% margin is
not uncommon for these kind
of appliances.
So I give you $700 more or
less per the cost of the goods.
So the forward supply chain of
Whirlpool is more or less $70.
Forward supply chain.
So it gives us like
$70 I guess per unit.
So it's 10% of our
sales price, $1,000.
30% margin, let's suppose if
our retailer they give us $700
is the cost of Whirlpool of
those 10% of distribution
costs.
So it gives $70 per unit.
Now the IFO cost
here-- this cost
includes selling
the scrap metals
and recovering all the
value of those metals.
If you get that out, this
costs you $80 per unit.
If you just look at
the direct costs of,
you know, recovering
all this material.
AUDIENCE: I just have
one other question.
So for the Whirlpool
forward chain,
that's the 10% of the cost,
but that is usually bringing it
to the retailer, right?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So should
we consider the fee
that is charged to customers
to get to their home?
Because for the
reverse supply chain,
we kind of would have to pick
them from the home, right?
PROFESSOR: So we could talk
about the network design,
as well.
Yeah.
Let's talk about the options
to try to be discussed.
But to get started,
these are the two numbers
we need to compare.
So $70 per unit is the cost
of getting to the dealer,
to the retailer, sorry-- or
the dealer of the appliance.
$70 per unit.
To get it back without getting
a scrap is $80 per unit.
Why is this higher, you
know, compared to this one?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
centralized distribution.
PROFESSOR: Centralized
distribution, right?
This, my network is not
designed to collect stuff.
So since it's not
designed to collect stuff,
the IFO model, even
if it's the IFO model,
Whirlpool is very
specialized in forward.
These numbers, even the
rough numbers-- this
is the kind of
environment that you
face the first time you go into
any reverse logistics cost.
That-- maybe the
numbers are not that big
when you look at the whole
Whirlpool corporation,
but when you start looking
back and try to nail down
and compute your
distribution costs,
This is more or
less the situation
you will face the
first time around.
Your forward cost per unit $70.
Your reverse could
be higher than that.
Mainly because you are not
using a optimized, well-designed
network.
Which get us to the
different options
that we have to
make this $80 down.
So it goes back to-- now we
can put a little bit more,
let's say, meat to this.
So if the IFO model, assuming
our estimates are OK,
costs us roughly $80
per unit, and this one
costs us roughly $70 per unit.
So if the IFO gets
super efficient,
and it really costs
me much less-- well,
actually it doesn't cost
me really $80 per unit.
It costs me $47.
But I can also do it here
and then sell the scraps.
That's why I'm computing
this one to the other.
So if the IFO pure
distribution costs get down
to much lower than $70, right,
maybe is worth doing with them.
If they can get to the
scale, and once they
recover the
investments, that they
have the plan-- if this number
gets less than $70, maybe
it's worth for me to jump there.
On a cost, pure cost
perspective, on the other hand,
we have some of the
other options here
that will give me value.
So with that, let me just ask
how will a closed loop-- how
do I want to compare the
actual networks to see
how different they are-- the
IFO versus the closed loop
network of Whirlpool?
So who wants to draw
a diagram of how
do you think Whirlpool
closed-loop supply chain could
look like?
Someone volunteers?
I'll volunteer someone.
How is the current
supply chain working?
Go for it.
You can use that one.
And let's go back to
where is the retailer,
where is the dealer,
and so forth.
Give it a shot.
AUDIENCE: So forward
supply chain,
you have one or two factories
where they make the stuff.
They go to a series of
regional distribution centers.
And each of these, in turn goes
to the series of retailers.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So there's actually how many
factories does Whirlpool have?
[? No one ?] remembers?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: I think
it was 17 in total.
AUDIENCE: Oh, but for--
PROFESSOR: Canada.
For Canada, yeah.
So 17 factories up there.
And those go to how many
DCs do they have in Canada?
Someone remembers?
More or less?
30?
40?
24.
24 DCs 24 DCs, and
how many retailers?
1,000?
How about 2,400?
2,400 retailers.
So that's the network.
17 factories, 24 real
distribution centers,
2,400 retailers.
Thank you.
Thank you for being brave.
Great.
So, how would the
IFO model look like?
If I join an IFO,
what will happen?
So let me just do a
little change to this
so we can add more models.
So we have a factory here.
And this will go to our original
distribution center, right?
And then this goes to a
bunch of different retailers.
The same diagram so that we
can just grow on this side.
So what happens if we
decide to join an IFO model?
If someone comes
with an IFO model,
what will happen at this
point with the goods?
Will I collect them
at the customer site?
So you think the
industry, the IFO,
what is a standard
producer responsibility?
So what does it mean?
That I have to be
collecting it or I
have to keep options to dispose?
What does the legislation
say more or less, or at least
the way it is described here?
AUDIENCE 1: Probably
just that you're
responsible for the ultimate
disposal of the product.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't say that
you have to go to your house
and pick it up, right?
It probably is not exactly
the way it will work.
The way it will work
is that you will set up
some sort of mechanism
to get those goods back.
And the ones that get back, you
are responsible for properly
disposing them.
And you have to create all the
right information, materials,
and incentives for the
consumers to know where and how
to dispose of these materials.
It's like batteries.
AUDIENCE: However, with the size
of stuff we're talking about,
refrigerators, and whatnot, I
think the only practical way
to do it is to go
get them for them.
Maybe they have to call
and make an appointment
several weeks out.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it will not be
Whirlpool in an IFO model.
More or less, the
way you will do it
is that you will probably
get the retailers
or another network
of dealers, probably.
That's the way you will do it.
That's the way it
works probably today.
You have a bunch
of dealers here.
[WRITING ON CHALK BOARD]
PROFESSOR: And
then these dealers
are the ones that go to
some sort of processor,
some entity here that
deals with steel,
sorry that deals with
decomposing the [INAUDIBLE]
to get the raw materials.
Out of the processors.
That's more or
less how the supply
chain will look like if you
do some sort of IFO model.
Someone pointed out one of the
things that you are missing out
is that you are losing that
connection with the consumer.
That's why I wanted
to draw the diagram.
So if you go to
an IFO model, you
will effectively remove your
connection with the dealers.
Maybe you wanted to do
that on that network.
Your consumer will
not have that.
Let's talk about
practical reasons.
Somebody mentioned this
will cost some money
to be able to collect
those goods from the house
of the consumer to the dealer.
How will you recover this money?
What happens today?
AUDIENCE: You charge
an up-front dealer,
and they buy the product.
PROFESSOR: That's
exactly the way it works.
All of us are paying for
this, we just do not know.
So when there is a
[? realization ?] like this
in Europe, or even
batteries in North America,
we are paid-- or
bottles-- or any kind
of mandated collection, we
are being charged for it.
We are-- it's not itemized.
And then what happens?
What happens with those dealers?
Once you get them
collected, the dealer says,
I have a Whirlpool here,
and I take a picture
of the Whirlpool, I scan it.
I send it to Whirlpool,
and Whirlpool gives me
the money they collected
so I can get back my cost.
That's how you pay
in these situations.
So you don't go and charge the
consumer for picking it up,
but they say, well
when you're done,
call one of these authorized
dealers' 1-800 number.
We'll pick up for
your appointment,
and then the dealer
goes and picks it up,
and then the whole
process continues.
That is probably
the most common way
that this actually is
implemented in practice.
So who bears the cost
ultimately is the consumer.
Which creates an
interesting dilemma.
If I'm charging
by consumer, can I
compete on the price
I charge my consumer?
I can charge less.
This goes back to loyalty and
other [INAUDIBLE] the customer.
What do you think about
the implementation
of these programs?
That is how maybe it
starts making sense
to try to get into it.
Because if I can
charge less for this,
I can actually sell my
product for less money,
for a prospective consumer.
Maybe.
I can try to do that.
How will the network
look like if I
use my-- the close look
now becomes apparent.
What I will ask my
consumers is, whenever
you purchased the computer,
we will take it back.
So I'm moving right now, so I
have all these things that I
buy for my new place.
And I go to Ikea a lot this
last weekend, I went a lot.
More times than I wanted to go.
And there's this big
heart with open hands.
Have you seen it?
We'll take it back.
So no matter when you
buy, we will take it back.
So you could tell your
customer the same.
If you bought your refrigerator
from Sears or from Kmart
or from Walmart, and it's
a Whirlpool refrigerator,
don't worry.
You can bring it back
when you're done with it.
And we will take it for you.
And in that opportunity,
I can also use that money
to give you a new refrigerator.
So that's the concept of also
engaging the consumer, where
you go to the same retailer
where you purchased the goods
and return that refrigerator,
washer and dryer, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
The question is, how do you
get it back from the retailers
to the rest of your network?
So one option is, which is
what GENCO does, pretty much,
is that you still
keep that connection.
But you can still have
a separate network.
You have another network
that goes back here,
where it goes back to
some sort of collector
where you aggregate
some of these flows.
And then you can get it back
to a processing facility that
can take care of it.
This gives you the
intimacy with the consumer
without having to deal
with the whole network.
But in that case you will
not get a cost advantage.
You will have probably higher
costs than the IFO model has,
because you don't
have enough volume.
Where you get the most
value is if you somehow
use the same flow, so
the same trucks that
collect and deliver your
goods to the retailer.
Those are the same
trucks you use.
You don't have to create
a new set of trucks.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: They're
coming empty anyway,
so why not bring them back?
Also their return
volume is not as high,
so it's not 100% of the sales.
So what is the main bottleneck,
then, for this to work?
If you want to use your
retailer and use your own trucks
that come empty.
Some problems we will
find with this approach.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so
why would I want to do it?
PROFESSOR: So that's
a big problem.
You are getting all this crap.
I have to have it
around in my warehouse,
or in my floor space.
I have to use a sales
associate to try
to spend time with the
customer and make sure it
is something I should take?
Any Whirlpool?
So that's the first barrier.
What's the other barrier?
That way you can fix, maybe you
can give them some incentives.
AUDIENCE: Oracle did
mention a systems barrier.
They're not able to trace
[INAUDIBLE] serial number
levels, so we can figure
out when these things are
going to be coming back.
PROFESSOR: That's another thing.
Which is the other one?
Who has ever kept a box of
the Whirlpool refrigerator?
How do you move those things
in a truck efficiently?
Luckily, things are
very nicely packed.
Not only because they're
beautiful for you,
but also easier to handle.
Your palate can now
go to the bottom,
and put on top of the palate.
Things are not sticking
out all over the place.
The doors are not
opened and closed.
So just the packaging of this
thing is meant to be moved.
Now once you return it,
it's just an easier scale.
So that creates
equipment [? tear. ?]
Eventually you have
to have more labor
to put it on top of the--
all those things are
the things that made it
a little more expensive.
But you can come up
with some solutions.
Some standard
wrapping or something.
But those are the
operational constraints
that you are probably getting.
Once you get to
face that problem,
and you get to your RDC,
you have the same problem
that the retailer has.
And that's you don't want to
have all this crap in your DCE
either.
So you have to have
another area of your DCE
so it doesn't
interrupt the flow.
So those are the
operational constraints
you have to face to set
up your own network.
And in some ways
or another, that's
what makes the IFO interesting.
So even though the
cost could be high,
all those little
barriers require
some really strong collaboration
with all your partners.
Your retailers need
to be on board.
You have to give them
some incentives either
on branding or market share,
some sort of incentive for them
to work with you.
Otherwise why would
they work with you?
And after that, you
still have to work
with all those physical
barriers of actually moving
used products back into where
they need to be disposed.
And those warehouses and
DCEs are not available.
You need more
investments, even if they
were huge capital investments.
They are big barriers on
operational investments.
And that's why companies like
GENCO are very profitable.
Because they still can
deal with that complexity,
and you don't have
to think about it.
In this case, Whirlpool
has a big advantage.
Market share-- 48% market share.
So you have the scale that you
need to work these details.
And if you can somehow
include the value of the brand
into this whole equation, that's
where this becomes attractive.
Operationally, it's a nightmare.
It's very upsetting to GENCO.
Once you get a certain scale,
like maybe Whirlpool has,
that's where you
can get into making
worthy investments plus you
get connection to the customer.
Which I think is ultimately,
just as a side note,
what Whirlpool decided to do.
Whirlpool, in this
particular case,
they actually decided to
go towards a closed loop.
But it was much more
expensive than they thought.
So it did not go that
well for our manager.
At least the first trial.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] They're
probably the first ones.
Maybe they can become
the IFO and everyone
else. can pay them to do it.
PROFESSOR: And that's exactly
what was the thinking.
The thinking was, well maybe
we could become the IFO.
At the end of the
day, the legislation
says, we pick one organization
to pick up everything.
So if things are not working
out, you could become the IFO.
So Whirlpool, in
this particular case,
they did decide to
try to close the loop.
And they actually talked, well
not in Canada, but in general,
they talked widely
about these things.
About how they are
taking things back
and as part of their
valuable position.
And they believe this is going
to give them some long term
value.
All right, so that was kind
of the underlying ripples.
So this is the way-- the
best data you can get
was in this case study.
You can get rough numbers
of how much it cost.
You have to look at
other initiatives,
the WEEE initiative.
In different places
of the world,
they publish this kind of
numbers, price of steel,
price of copper,
estimated number of units,
and roughly going those.
The mapping of the costs
here was a little bit harder.
You need to have the
inside information.
That's why you use 10%.
But this is how you probably
can think through understanding
what is the right trade off.
That's always a good benchmark.
Try to compute
how much it costs.
Forward versus reverse.
And that will give you a sense
of what-- don't be surprised
if it is twice as much,
30% as much, 40% more
than your forward, because
it's not optimized.
And later it will become better.
Volume is here the
key to do that.
And on homogeneous products
like the case of Whirlpool,
their boxes-- [INAUDIBLE]
boxes-- makes it more viable.
For a retailer, that's why
their GENCO starts with.
You have shirts and
toys and cell phones.
Everything in one bundle,
then maybe collecting
to your former supply
chain is not as easy
because the box is hard
to fit in your truck.
Boxes like these
ones are easier.
All right, Any other thoughts or
comments on the Whirlpool case?
Tony or Alex, is there
anything I should add?
Great lecture?
OK, great.
Let's keep going.
So now I want to talk
about the final projects.
So I want each of you
to come here in front
and quickly tell the
rest of the group what
are you doing, which
companies you picked,
and that's what I ask
for your [INAUDIBLE]
Did everyone find a
nice clean green area
in the [? work site ?]
of your companies?
With Alexis we joke, every
time we look at companies,
they all say it is
eating our values, right?
It's in our DNA.
That's the word I use.
So every single company
and website [INAUDIBLE]
the world should
be a better place.
So the other company
is Indie Tech Zara.
OK, so I can tell you
have lots of questions
next class about how to compute
carbon footprint of energy
and stores, and electricity.
I think that's going to be
something to understand well
because I'm sure all
your companies have that
highlighted somehow.
So are they smoke and mirrors,
or they're doing the real deal,
I guess?
We have to have to see after--
no pressure, Tony, but--
AUDIENCE: I might have
more questions after
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: After the lecture.
Great, so you know
that's Zaragoza,
our center is actually in the
same logistics park as Zara,
largest distribution
center in Spain.
So that's one reason why our
partner center is in Zaragoza
partly, co-located
with the plaza that
is the logistics
activity zone of Zaragoza
where the largest distribution
center of Zara is.
To manage all the
global operations.
They also fly things
around from there.
OK great, thank you.
So let's pick the next one.
Any questions or comments
before I move to the next group?
No?
All right.
Let me see.
So the next one is
Hewlett Packard and Delll,
So thank you.
I would like to just
highlight these two projects.
So we look at, first
two pairs of companies
have very different
business models.
Zara has one, fast fashion,
lots of designs per year.
Dell goes direct to consumer.
And I think that really
has deep implications.
And I think both of you
highlighted that's important.
I also want to
point out, at least,
the state of both
industries in terms
of environmental practices.
Electronics industry has moved
together for a longer time.
There's the WEEE
directive in Europe.
They put electronics
under scrutiny,
so they're both under
higher pressure.
That's why maybe you see
more of the same initiatives
like take materials
out of certain kind.
It's outlawed in some countries.
So you have to do it
because you have to do it.
So there's a little
bit of that on one end.
They also tend to collaborate in
other sectors, both the apparel
industry and the
electronics industry.
They collaborate on social
issues on a parallel for labor.
So that brings them
together in other forums.
In electronics, they also get
together for technology designs
to keep processors high speed.
So as you go into
both of your cases,
take a look at maybe there's
some underlying themes that
are common to the industry
that have brought,
because of the industry really.
And the US consumer has no
idea about these things,
so for you it looks like every
company is doing the same.
But this probably comes
from some other force.
So in both cases, I know,
especially electronics.
[INAUDIBLE] apparel are
more on that band width.
So let's keep that in mind.
All right good, let
me see who is next.
BMW.
So I think that this
is interesting to know
that the company that started
the brand with the consumer--
hybrid notion-- is not
the top rated company.
You will imagine that where the
largest emissions are in a car
is in the usage.
So if you innovated there,
why are you number one
for the next 25 years?
But it looks like it's not.
So I think that it's
interesting to know that.
I also did not mention
much about the life cycle
aspect of it in both
of these companies.
It's very different
and in textiles-- Tony,
I don't remember in
textiles or Alexis--
the life cycle
emissions are not in use
except if you
consider water energy
use for washing your clothes.
That probably dwarfs the
other emissions then.
Do you remember, Tony?
The life cycle
emissions of apparel,
in general, or in the tex--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's the
wash, if it's the wash.
PROFESSOR: So don't wash
your clothes if it's the--
AUDIENCE:High efficiency.
PROFESSOR: High efficiency--
no, don't wash them.
Or use a solar washer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this again
goes back to the life cycle
and which pieces you
control versus you
don't control of
their life cycle.
But great.
Thank you.
Let's look at the other group.
Phillip Morris International.
OK thank you.
I just want to add the comment
on do you work internally
in your operations
or you do offsets?
Plant trees, or--
we'll talk a little bit
about that over time.
But I'm glad that
one of the companies
here highlighted offsets as
one of the strategies they
wanted to pursue.
Let me see.
The other one is-- so I skipped.
So for our next class, the case
studies [INAUDIBLE] is ready?
The [INAUDIBLE] case study?
GUEST SPEAKER: It's been
posted, it's pretty simple,
so hopefully asking
good questions
about what you're actually
the mechanics of doing
calculations, et cetera,
You can email me directly
with those questions.
But have that filled out and
turned in by Wednesday morning
because we'll-- I'm going to
collect some of the data from
that [INAUDIBLE]
discuss it during class.
PROFESSOR: And you have to
use the numbers for that one.
There's no way to escape it.
There's a bunch of sales
questions you have to work on.
GUEST SPEAKER: It requires
only basic multiplication
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Thank you again.